I found this strange as the newest
justice on the Supreme Court this is
true Gorsuch is going to be forced to
perform low-level jobs such as heading
up the cafeteria committee and opening
doors for the other judges that's true
that's a real thing it turns out it
turns out this is actually part of a
long-standing tradition of hazing the
new Justice that's a real that's a real
thing they do you become a Supreme Court
justice highest post on the land and you
have to go through a hazing crazy yeah
well here's a look at the other
degrading things Gorsuch had to endure
here score such picking up the other
judges dry-cleaning he had to get that
Perry is walking Justice Roberts his
prize show dogs here the other justice
they're gambling him in here's a coffee
shock he's giving Ruth Bader Ginsburg a
piggyback ride to get her morning coffee
here they are forcing him to do a
Jagermeister funnel through the
Constitution
and currently there's the House of
Representatives and there's Gossage
streaking true that's so humiliating
when you streak in front of a woman
stenographer and she doesn't even look
up they're using yeah I know
she's just they're clicking away she
could care less she's just as typing
unimpressive
you